pumpkin you told us in march you were
ready to leave the show
do you still want to leave the show i am
ready to
walk away from it and live a normal life
how's everybody doing and why did you
feel it's important to get back together
to do an interview
um because we have like mended our
relationship
and working on a relationship every day
this is our first interview together
since um we've actually had the reunion
on the show
what y'all [ __ ] doing
how's it been filming together a lot i'm
going to start with you how has it been
for you
um together it's been good but it's also
very negative because mama is very loud
very but we're actually still filming
this season
we don't grab this season of the era now
until next week
wow well pumpkin how's it been for you
i think that's been really good like i
said it is hectic when momma is around i
feel like we get less done
when she is on set for sure
how is it to be with her now pumpkin
how's it
to be with your mama now i think
definitely compared to where we were two
years ago it's definitely a big
transformation
it's definitely been rough and hard but
it's definitely getting better now
do you feel like your mom is finally
picking you
over other things yeah i feel like she's
finally putting us
as a priority now what's the point in
doing it if the most important person
that i want to be here for everything in
my life the important parts the sad
parts whatever it is
it's not even there to see me june when
you had to sit down with your children
you had to hear them
talk about how they were struggling how
they missed you how much they were hurt
what did that how'd that make you feel i
mean as a parent you don't want to hear
that
um but you know i i'm glad that they
were able to express that and that we
are starting to move forward um pumpkin
always says babies except baby steps i
think that we're actually like
into like the walking toddler stages
now what what does that mean what kind
of relationship is the walking toddler
stages mean
mama is the type of person who just kind
of wants to forget the past and let's
not talk about it
but in order for us that's not really
like how we
how i am raising my family now i'm not
like that
the toddler steps really are more of
like
we're talking about the past and we're
starting to move forward
you don't know how many nights i cried
myself to sleep
just hoping and praying that you don't
overdose
there was even a point where you know
you said you thought that one day you
were going to find out she was going to
od and you'd never see her again
i think that was a bigger fear for all
of us really like it wasn't just
like i wanted to major the blunt of it
because she is younger you know she
can't really
survive without her mom or someone
taking care of her she's still a child
and a lot of people forget that
but i think that was definitely a word
for all of us especially
how quickly the addiction progressed and
some of that
it was definitely one of our main
concerns
do me what i want to ask you how you're
doing how are you doing health-wise now
i mean
there was a point where you and geo you
spent over 150
000 on drugs is that right a lot more
than that
but really
like 10 times more than that yeah hold
on you're telling me you spent a million
you're telling me you spent a million
dollars on drugs
i'm over with like the last week of the
last year of our audition
we're now like six over 16 months clean
um and you know for
you know now i see my bank account
looking nice i don't think about those
things like
i'm big into the recovery community and
the girls know that
i've definitely seen a bigger change
they say they say i'm more emotional
than i used to be
she really wasn't the one to kind of
like say i love you and stuff when she
hung up the phone or when we laugh
but now she does that every time i get
on the phone every time i leave
and all that stuff so it's definitely a
completely different person even like
free a day before addiction you're still
with gino right yes
how's your relationship um i mean it's
going i mean like i said i mean you know
everybody has like little things that
they need to work out but i mean it's
going pretty good
has he also stayed clean yes
um over 16 months also pumpkin how are
you feeling about geno now
um you know like mama said like there is
a lot of stuff that we all have to work
on like my top priority
at the beginning was you know fixing
things with my mom of course because she
is my mom
alana you good
just i haven't seen him in so long so
it's a little
it's a little much and you know gino has
come along and he has apologized and he
has
definitely i feel like been honest and
open about what happened during
the addiction pumpkin you told us in
march you were ready to leave the show
i want to go ahead and say goodbye if
i'm being completely honest i want to go
and be a nurse at a hospital
are you okay now with it or do you still
want to leave the show
i am ready to walk away from it and live
a normal life
and just live with me and my family
instead of having to go out to the
restaurant
and 75 people stop us for a picture but
i just think i'm at a point where i've
been doing this for so
long we've been doing it for almost 10
years and i feel like i just kind of at
some point want to definitely step away
alana get on your zoom classes i've
taken this off
we honestly think our life is kind of
boring even though our life is always
crazy and chaotic
but you know there's been those fans
that's loved us
there and in between and in a way
i do feel like it may be close
to the time for us to just to kind of
kind of the kardashians bow out
and say thank you we appreciate it you
know
we may have like one more season in us
um and then i don't think that you know
at that point what more is there to
film i i hear you
um alana as you've grown up and you see
these headlines now about your mom
and your family how hard is that and
what goes through your mind when you
see those headlines i mean it's hard
seeing a bunch of different headlines
about everything
because like i just like why does my
life got to be so
public like why does everything got to
be out there like you know so it is a
little harder to see everything
oh like all the headlines and stuff but
i just got to deal with it it's my life
now
i want to be here for y'all and i want
to be the best mom
i can be after going through all this
stuff and
you saw and you finally understood how
your children were suffering
what noun do you say that first alana
means to you
um i mean the girls have always meant
the world to me
and i know that may not have been people
might not think that you're my addiction
um for alana you know i am very proud
you know she's going into 11th grade
i mean she's almost reason to graduate
um
she's you know become the person that
she is
and you know i have told her that i'm
sorry for her having to deal with that
for so young
young it really was just us girls it
really was just
me now taking care of alana jessica ella
like i've matured but it's also been
overwhelming dealing with it too because
i had to grow up a lot more than i
wanted to and then when it comes to like
pumpkin
like i am very proud of her i do thank
her a lot i'm very grateful
that she stepped up when i couldn't even
take care of my damn sale
you know pumpkins you know buying bought
a house and
living you know a good life for 21 so
she's actually doing really good
do you tell her that a lot because it is
phenomenal how she has taken on this
role
um yeah i mean i'm not going to tell her
as an auditor all the time
no but like i mean she knows that i've
been grateful for her
pumpkin how do you how do you feel now
towards your mom is everything patched
up and do you
you kind of understand i feel like
things are still
being passed up i don't feel like
they're quite
sealed just yet but i do feel as if
we are on that way to stealing the
patches and moving past
all that stuff for sure it has to be
hard having all these responsibilities
i mean i definitely think that it's hard
and it's definitely a struggle
it was more of a struggle in the
beginning now just it's just
life like i'll get up every day and make
sure elon's at school
and you know make sure that there's
groceries in the house i
you know i do feel as if in the
beginning it was definitely
something that i was not used to
something that i kind of was just
learning as i go what still bothers you
i just think there's a lot of things
that still bother me the distance you
know with her living in florida
you know i take care of everybody so
you know another thing is with my mama
too with her living in florida
i can't really take care of you six and
a half hours away
june why won't you move back um i mean
who never knows what the future holds
but don't you want to be near your girls
i told them
over and over again you know in my
addiction
i was selfish but in my recovery i'm
also
selfish and i have to make my recovery
number one for and foremost if i don't
and i just keep on running life
then you're not working that program
like you're supposed to
so i have said that for a year i was
hoping to get a job at the rehab
uh but there wasn't no openings and so
you know they know that
you know there's a possibility that i
can move back to georgia it's just
a lot of stuff that needs to be tied up
in florida first you have a court date
coming up correct
i've already had it you've already had
it so where does it stand now where does
everything stand now report wise
um you just have to watch this season
and see how it turns out
how about gino is he is he done with all
his court stuff
no you're awesome you'll also
see that with the show also how scary is
it for you going into court and dealing
with the court system and there's always
the op
there's always the chance that you could
go back to prison um i mean it's been
hard
um it's been you know kind of crazy it's
like a dark cloud above your head that
never goes away even though
you're not living that life anymore um
so that's the hard thing june you did a
show about
reshaping your body have you come to
peace with that now
and is that kind of in your past um
you know yeah i am okay with where i am
i've
thought about doing what they call
revision surgery
um because in code i have a gain like a
hundred pounds
and so like only 100
but i mean you know so for me
you know i want to try to lose this
weight and it's been really hard
i love my fat case too much so you
really would think about
doing surgery again um the revision part
of it
i have thought about yes could that be a
shoe
no not for the show-wise no no for
myself
just to feel i mean i never want to be
as skinny as i was when i first did the
first season of mama juice not out i was
a size
two and like i don't want to be that
that much that skinny but
like i do want to try to at least lose
like 78 pounds
maybe we could do this again okay
no fussing no fighting i promise alana
how's your relationship with your dad
is non-existent it's not there at all
what's so bad is it's been like that all
of her life which is sad because he was
not
raised like that um well i mean i really
wouldn't say that it's been all her life
i mean he was taking care and
physically seeing her up until 2015
we moved to henry county and then that's
when he started seeing jennifer
and what's he got with jennifer it was a
completely different ballgame like he
didn't have nothing to do with her
the texts were like he wasn't sending
them
and then as you guys seen on last season
at the end of the season like we had
that big book in the front yard
that was real don't don't no don't give
her your man that [ __ ]
you too you [ __ ] that's why i have
custody
that was real feelings because i as
the person taking care of alana and when
we tell him like hey alan doesn't want
to be around you doesn't want to see
anymore he thinks we're just saying that
so i want him to hear from strictly
alana's mouth
and it's like he couldn't even get that
out because jennifer has 700 things to
say
so alana probably what a month or two
ago
probably even longer than that she kind
of blocked his contact has
so you're done alana yeah i'm done
i feel like i've tried and begged him to
be in my life for so long and he's just
showing me that he just don't care
so i'm done big and like for him to be
in my life
i guess for me you know it's it's sad
that you know
he doesn't have anything to do with her
or any of my children's
you know i don't look at it as being sad
for him or giving him any pity
i think that really that's his fault
and really it's his loss i hear you um
by the way alana you're in 11th grade
now right
she will be coming this school year
you're going into 11th grade
that means boys oh yes
is it oh really explain to me what's
going on with the boys
she does have a little boyfriend who
like comes over and stuff like he comes
over for like dinners and stuff he's
very respectful
so it is nice to he comes to family
dinners
yes he does so everyone approves of him
so how is that alana having a boyfriend
say hello
[Music]
like respectful has not only has respect
for like
us when he comes into our household he
also has respect for alana
like him and ella are the best of
friends so
it is nice to have somebody around that
treats her well but also treats like
my family love their family so you
approve
yes yes pumpkin approved when mama said
we was going to six flags
i was so excited it almost came out of
my skin
i'll be weird i'll be riding around to
just in my bones
alana you've been on tv pretty much your
entire life
how is that and how do you handle when
people jump on social media and they may
say
negative things about you how do you
deal with that fascist
i mean i just deal with it like i don't
really care about [ __ ] something i
don't really care i don't i'm gonna do
what i want to do regardless because
my life is my life so i don't really
care what people
16 is already it's tough enough right
it is hard but i mean i think i'm
cooking pretty well
like her biggest thing is people her her
lashes
her nails that's what you're just saying
i'd see on social media
and i i tell people pumpkin has went to
the bat for her i would have ever
like she was four years old doing lashes
nails hair so what's the difference now
this is fashion
[Music]
10 years later when she's doing those
things
as a teenager a lot of people have
stepped to her defense actually saying
that that's the kind of thing that
young ladies do experiment with at this
time that
it should you shouldn't be worried about
what she's doing if that's the worst
thing she's doing then so be it
exactly exactly how has it been for you
pumpkin being a mom
basically now to a teenager you know
it's
not only being a mom just a teenager
like i also take care of my older sister
just to go to as you guys
seen on the show so it's me
josh it's my little girl ella i'm also
pregnant again
now it's alana and jessica
so it definitely it definitely is a lot
of times but i think i've managed pretty
well
you know to kind of not go on britney
spears and shaved my head off just
yet but it i mean
listen you're a young woman you should
still be enjoying your life to some
extent alana how are you doing
health-wise because i know you were
working on your health and eating
healthier um i
feel like i'm doing good now i'm doing
better than i was
sure i told her i've noticed in the last
couple months she's been losing
um i guess what they call baby fat i
guess like she's coming
into herself but i have noticed that
in the last couple of months she has a
lot of fun don't be rolling your eyes
what do you hope to do just be healthy
alana
uh mainly this is what i want overall
you enjoy sharing pictures on social
media don't you
yeah she posts more than any of us i
think
she's in love with herself which is a
good thing yeah tell me what is it you
love about the pictures you take
um everything i just
i just know i'm pretty and i know
i know i'm a bad beat how do the kids
react to you
when i first went to my school the kids
was like oh my god it's honey boo boo
it's honey boo
but i've been there for a minute now so
everybody's like
it's a long now you know it's right
she's just another one of us now are you
done by the way with honey boo boo you
don't want anybody to call you honey boo
boo
do you um people still do call me honey
baby but i do feel like that was younger
me
i feel like now i am moana like that's
my name taught me my name you know
but i mean i don't mind the whole
honeymoon are you thinking about going
to college after high school
um i'm not completely sure yet but i
think i am going to go to college
and i want to go to college to be a
nurse and like to meet you or something
oh wow where do you want to go to
college if you had your choice where do
you want to go
um i want to go to college in texas why
why texas and where in texas um
anywhere in texas really i just want to
go to texas there has to be something
about texas
they say things always be here in texas
right
will you go get your ged yeah um
i just like i'm about to start taking
classes for it now
oh congratulations on that and good luck
good luck
pumpkin what do you do um i'm doing the
end of july
at the end of july are you ready yeah
i'm i'm ready to be done
that's for sure pregnancy
both times for me have been pretty
exhausting
and this time i'm pregnant through the
summer like really pregnant
and i'm not having it alan are you ready
to be in on again
um yes i am raised we're on again i've
been waiting
for another little baby to come around
pumpkin will you let june be around your
daughter and also your new baby now
oh yeah um like as you guys seen on the
show too like they met up and stuff
like in the addiction there was no way
in
in no time for hill what i was going to
let alana orella around her uh knowing
that i said that she was in and
obviously as an adult and i want to be
around her
but i feel like now i'm more comfortable
you know we come and hang out and we do
dinners together and stuff like that
but yeah i definitely feel 100 way more
comfortable now that she is
clean and sober and showed us you know
the soap
levels and steps that i asked her to
take i'm
very well comfortable with putting the
kids traffic
when i'm not when i'm here in georgia
she definitely wants to see me as much
as possible but when i go back to
florida and we're on facetime
she all she wants to do is come to the
beach but i mean like
like she does really really like
with teen she just likes every all the
family to be together which is
[Music]
amazing
you